air france devra voler de ses propres
ailes en tout cas sans l'état qui
détient aujourd'hui 54 % du capital et
qui va bientôt devenir très minoritaire
malgré la crise qui secoue le transport
aérien depuis le 11 septembre
air france se porte bien c'est donc la
compagnie aérienne qui ouvre le bal des
privatisations version raffarin stéphane
despinoy les avions arbore toujours les
trois couleurs bleu blanc rouge
et pourtant l'état ne sera bientôt plus
que minoritaire dans la compagnie trois
ans et demi après la première ouverture
du capital le gouvernement raffarin a en
effet décidé de faire figurer air france
à la première place sur la liste des
privatisations
l'état pourrait ainsi descendre dès
l'automne de 54% à moins de 20% du
capital au cours du jour à savoir 14
euros l'opération devrait faire tomber
dans les caisses publiques plus d'un
milliard d'euros mais le gouvernement en
attend plus la privatisation aura donc
lieu lorsque les conditions du marché le
permettront
pour les salariés d'air france pas de
changement dans l'immédiat ils
conserveront leur statut pendant deux
ans
l'annnonce de cette privatisation a en
tout cas surpris les syndicats alors que
la compagnie dégage des profits et a
réussi à nouer des alliances
ironie de l'histoire il y a huit ans
l'état était venu au secours d'une
compagnie moribonde il s'apprête
maintenant à privatiser un pavillon
mondialement reconnu